okay welcome uh
everyone uh to the
gdpr seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and logistics as usual
uh first of all please mute yourself
during the talk
unless you have questions if you do have
questions you are welcome to unmute
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that
we can address them in q and a session
at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences
and therefore no classified discussion
is allowed so watch out
and finally the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded
in your you in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host 10 britain who is
an
associate professor of the odin
institute for computational engineering
and sciences and the department of
aerospace engineering and engineering
mechanics
at the university of texas at austin
tan obtained his phd from mit
in 2007 master of sciences from
singapore
mit alliance in 2003 and bachelor degree
uh from ho chi minh city university of
technology in 2001
he has decades of experience and
expertise on multidisciplinary research
across the boundaries of different
branches of computational science
engineering and mathematics and has been
plenary keynote speakers at various
international conferences and workshops
uh tan is currently uh the elected vice
president of the scion texas
louisiana section the elected secretary
of the siam
siag cse an associated
editor of science journal on scientific
computing
on editorial board member of the
elsevier
computer and mathematics with
applications and an
associate editor of the elsevier journal
of computational physics
pen was an nsf only courier recipient
and the odin institute distinguished
research award and
a two-time winner of the moncrief
faculty
challenging award okay today
and will uh present model constrained
deep
learning approaches for inference
control
and uncertainty quantification which is
a great interest to us so please enjoy
and expect a wonderful talk from tan
now without further ado let me pass the
button to 10 by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question
is if you had the walls
attention for 30 seconds what would you
say
if i had what i'm sorry say again one
more question
if you had walls the whole world's
attention
for 30 seconds
maybe you are in the television everyone
is watching you right
what would you say oh well i would say
that you know be united uh work together
wonderful i like that answer okay it's
all yours tim
yeah all right thanks you so for for
inviting
me to give a talk here to share my
research on
my recent research on deep learning for
ingress problems
and uh everybody if you have questions
please stop me anytime um
it's supposed to be very casual even
though you have 52 slides i don't have
to go through these right um so some of
them are gonna
glance very quickly especially theorems
there's no need to go into details
um all right so uh behind the scenes
as always right uh these are my students
and postdocs
from left to right and from top to
bottom the last person on the bottom is
is my poster
who just left back to his country
and uh i appreciate the funding from
d.o.e and nsf and a couple of dollars
about
other companies and an organization okay
so my
my main interest my main interest on
inverse problem um optimization and uq
so let me actually give you a very quick
just introduction on a couple of
problems that i have been working before
so the one that i've shown
you here is the uh electromagnetic
scattering problem the one the movie
that i show you here is showing the
electromagnetic scanning from half of
the aircraft
so the forward problem you are given the
shape right or the material property
uh and you just solve for the
electromagnetic
waves or field over the domain of
interest
um that's a full problem i think
everybody know basically you saw a pdes
the inverse problem is more difficult
um in the inverse problem you have a
measurement that's a few points thinking
about radar right you send the radar
and the radar see some object reflects
and then you can measure the radar at
the field point so in times or
in space right uh question that's can
you reconstruct the object or not
right and you have to take into account
the fact that the data is limited it's
also
due to the limitation of manufacturing
process your
measuring device is uh limited in the
accuracy
how how can you reconstruct your object
right and
for us that's not the only question that
we want to
address uh we addressed a little bit
more uh we
not only give the solution what the
object should look like but also what is
uncertainty associated with our solution
right especially if something that
more is important for decision making
right something actually can have a
you know big consequence uncertainty
associated with your your solutions
and we want to do so in a large scale
setting uh okay so the the next
application is a
seismic wave propagation so this is a
japanese earthquake that we the forward
simulation that i show you here when you
have the earthquakes and if you
assume that you know the earth materials
then
um and then you can actually solve the
earth uh um
weights right um earthquakes way
propagation inside the earth like i'm
showing you here right
for us we just use the elasticity
equations and that's quite quite uh um
um outstanding uh and it's difficult um
so the
the inverse problem is more difficult in
a sense that you have measurements right
you put the thermometer listen to the
earth movement at
few points or many points in the u.s you
recover quite well right that's a
project where you have about you know
500 or some 700
thermometer you move it around the u.s
listen to the earth and okay so after
you listen to the earth you
measure the displacement of the earth
question is that can you image the
interior what is the
material properties right where's the
fault especially you guys most of you i
mean i think most of you are here in
california
uh earthquake is really important of
course we don't claim that we can
predict the earthquakes but if we have
some you know uh um idea on how the
earth
uh the earth structure look like where
the fall is and what is the possibility
right
that the earthquakes can happen in the
future that's
that's important and more importantly we
also can you know
design houses and and put some code that
you know
many house or building needs to satisfy
for the particular regions
all right that is close to the earth's
epicenter for example
and again um the measurements are
limited and
uh um only accommodate with noises or
error the question is that can you
actually
invert for the material of the earth
image inside the earth so this is
another one contaminated
flow that i'm showing you here so w is
is a concentration you can think that
way use an initial
uh concentration for example this is you
are the initial conditions
and over time it's actually convective
and and
diffuse uh we only can have measurements
at in time at the viewpoint for example
i can measure
the concentration of the pollution at a
couple points here
question is that what is where the
pollution come from right so that we
can chase company or whoever
organization put the
pollution uh right inside the water or
whatever
so we this is this is kind of important
um or you know if you're on a cd if the
air is polluted where does it come from
so if you can think of that way
and this is another english problem
because you only have a measure limited
measurement of the concentration at the
final time for example
but we want to actually go back right
backward in time to find what is the
concentration distribution initially
okay
um another example okay maybe this is
this is the easiest one heat conduction
um
problem everybody knows so if you can
measure the the temperature on the
outside the fin
what is it what is the material right
again the material is yield that's what
i'm talking here
so what i'm showing you so far this
different type of
inverse problem this the first one the
electromagnetic scattering
problem is non-linear right the
earthquakes are also non-linear this is
a linear inverse problem because
you invert for the initial conditions
this is again non-linear problem for
heat condition
okay just a couple of problems there's
many many many many more uh english
problems in in reality so it may perhaps
the the one
closer to everybody is like ultrasound
cc scan radar and so on and so forth
these are english problems all right so
what are the challenges
uh with uh with associated with inverse
problems what i'm going to show you a
very simple thing just to put us into
perspective let's say we want to do it
uh to solve the um deterministic
optimization problem right to figure out
the inverse solution right so so g here
basically
what it does is that okay if you give me
u i can solve for the solution with your
concentration
and then i try to see my concentration
match the observation or not
right and and if you do inverse problem
you know it's it's well
it's in ill pose sorry because the
measurement is limited
right uh so use g here is a map from
what from u which is very high
dimensional space it can be
infinite dimensional space for us it is
infinite dimensional space because it's
a spatial distribution
right spatially distributed by
parameters and the observation is
actually
finite so you see that the map from
infinite or very large dimension to
small dimension
it does not have the invert right
doesn't have inverse and we know that
the new space can be big and small and
so on and so forth
the more interesting problem in the uh
english problem setting is that
the stability right suppose that you can
get this so
you can solve english problem you want
your solution actually uh uh
not sensitive to the noise right that's
that's important because otherwise a
little bit of noise in the data is gonna
blow up
on the whole solution and we get garbage
all right
so in order to deal with that situation
typically you have to add some
regularization
on the prior impulsion uh english
problem you have to add them prior
um or inverse one the main point is to
make it it will pose so that the
solution is unique and
then the solution depends continuously
on the data which is why i observe here
and what you can see here if you haven't
worked with inverse problem before
it's very easy idea right this is thick
enough but what is it right it's just
add a parabola
because you know that you know if
there's a parabola then there's a unique
it's a good parabola that you have to
solve for the minimizer right
then you know that there's a unique
solutions and we know that this is not a
good one because it due to
imposedness so you just simply add a
parabola here to make it
real well posed right so that's not the
key idea behind
ticking up and also gaussians prior if
you
if you wish all right so the the
um what are the challenges with the
inverse formula first
is the high dimensional state uh the w
so this is associated
um notice right right if you haven't
worked with the english problem before
this is how
we i understand about inverse problem if
the forward
equation you solve only one if you know
the boundary condition you know initial
condition
you solve for for w you solve it once
and that's it right english problem is
nothing more than solving the forward
problem many times
right so now that's become important
because if
each of the you know forward solution is
very expensive uh the whole
the home the whole inverse procedure is
actually very expensive so that's that's
one of the the first challenge which
we may not see in in in the forward
problem right we don't really see or if
you saw very large scale problem i'm
sure
at national left you saw a real
large-scale problem
sold one on really expensive now if you
solve it many times that's
almost impractical right so we have to
deal with that issue the second issue is
high dimensional parameter speed
you so either you do deterministically
by
optimization and high dimensionals right
space or you do beijing's if you listen
you have to assemble
right you have the same but the
posterior distribution in high
dimensional space and we know
we know that there's a curved
dimensionality um
because dimensionality basically say
that as the dimension goes right
it grows the cost grows exponentially
so you have we have to deal with that
issues right that you may not we may not
see if we solve
in forward problem all right the last
last uh
challenge is the high dimensional data
like the earthquakes problem that i
showed you before
we have measurements of the the movement
of the earth every you know
millisecond or so and we can have
terabytes of data in
one second on one millisecond questions
that how you can deal with that because
we know right
computing system is not it's not it's
not compute valve but
but memory valve so if if the memory is
limited which we do
if we have a lot a huge amount of data
we have problem with io and io can be
making very slow
so these are three challenges that we
have to deal with and over the years
we develop many methods doing dealing
different issues
so what i'm going to do today is is
focus on one particular
aspect right so we're not going to do
assembling problem
we're going to ignore the high
dimensionality uh uh
um of the data as well we're going to
try to solve the inverse problem um
in good sense we're going to try the
solving but problem using machine
learning
and the way that we do is that we're not
gonna do machine learning in
in the way that you know in the computer
science community
that is we're not we're not gonna use it
directly right because we know
for science and engineering problem the
data is limited
right so we don't have a regime where
you have a huge amount of data so that
you can train
the neural network for example we have a
limited data and
noisy data question is that can you
actually learn the inverse problem
and in order to do that we have to we
have to encode the physics
right and encode the the underlying
problem into the training so that that's
the key goal for
for for today and in order to achieve
that goal i'm going to do
uh two ways right i'm going to do purely
data driven i just
data driven deep learning just
completely exactly or exactly what
machine um computer science give us
right deep learning training so on and
so forth
data only i'm going to show you how we
learn
inverse map and forward map at the same
time or or
independently and you want to see how
the results look like and on the right
side here
we're gonna we're gonna encode the the
underlying mathematical model inside the
training uh process right
inside the deep learning process um the
question how we're gonna do it we're
gonna show you again
how to learn the english map you can
stream by the forward map and learn the
pigments might use it and
also it's an uncertainty so this is just
you know
our uh some of the effort that we're
going to share with you
um so let me start with the first
attempt so
in this case we're going to do with pure
data deep learning approach and we're
going to do so for both
forward and inverse problem so to put
our cell on
on the same page especially notations nt
here
is the number of training uh data um you
little you remember that low k usually
the parameters
so capital u um is is the h column the
capital use is one
instant of u by the way we're gonna do
in a finite dimensional setting right so
you have m and t
instead of the uh parameters right
and then we also have observation
corresponding to parameters so
this is what i assume that we have so
together u and
and y or y and u is a training data set
that's that indentation and the norm
here
unless otherwise stated each of the
euclid euclidean norm for the vectors or
probabilities norm for matrix uh for
symbolics or simplicity
and another notation that we're going to
use throughout the talk is that fee
here the first argument is input and the
second argument is a way in biases so
this is a deep
neural net okay so um the first naive
deep learning net
that we're gonna do is to to do this
right
we want to learn the different net that
map from the
the data to the parameter that's in
that's inverse map right
the fourth map is to take the parameter
and give you the observation the english
might be
from observation and try to get back to
uh the parameters
okay so this is the first term is trying
to learn the inverse map
of course we know that's not going to be
working well because it's the you post
so we
we the the the obvious one on you know
it's not shouldn't say it's obvious but
it's
not easy way to put the l2
regularization for both the way and
biases right
um it's just for the sake of the
discussions all right
if you do that well what do you get uh
you
you immediately can can get something
but unfortunately we cannot do a
non-linear problem
in order to get insight into the the
ability of the deep learning iron what
or what learning deep learning can do
we're going to simplify things right so
that we can see things better
analytically so i'm going to assume that
the the problem is now linear inverse
problem and we also assume that linear
neural network right in the sense that
the map from the input
to to the um from the uh to the from the
observation which is the input to the
output which is the u
is it's linear right you can you can do
that with the allele right
so so that's that is no problem okay so
linear inverse problem linear neural
network what can you do
so you can solve you can solve the
optimization this optimization problem
um sorry what is that here you can solve
this optimization problem
analytically and this is the solution
for the the way and biases
analytically and this is your your um
english solution
right uh the problem is that if you look
at here i mean we can write it down
everybody can write
in in this talk everybody can do it
question that's what is it here well i
can
i don't know right it's not uh
interpretable for me at least right
okay so so the the the message
is is the first method is that it's not
clear what it does but it can give you
solutions
all right so that's it to learn the
inverse map directly
so the the second approach that i'm
going to show you now is to learn
through the outer encoder technique
right if you do i know doing so and many
of you do model reduction which i also
did
when i was in my phd and also recently
um again um the
the the the message here right all the
problem is to
to map from the data so look at this is
the data right and this is the
observation so this is an inverse map
that we're going to learn
but we don't want to learn that alone we
want to learn it with the forward right
we we not only learn that for inverse
map but we also want to learn the
forward map at the same time
so and this is you know if you look it
out and code it this is this is the
other
encoder right nothing more than that the
only difference is that
we don't have the latent variable we
actually force the latent variable to be
the the parameter so observation to
parameter
parameter back to observation so this
allowed to learn both
simultaneously the the inverse and the
forward at the same time right one
actually
rarely the others of course right you
can do the other way around as well that
is
parameter to observation and two
parameters which we're going to show
some results on that as well
but not shown here in the pictures okay
so the idea is still the same we want to
learn
the outer encoder right such that it's
metadata because the data coming in
go through the encoder and go back to go
through the decoder and back to the
observation
right and the latent variable is
parameter that's important
all right so uh we regularized
um by uh by this fact right the fact
that
the latent variable is the uh the
parameter is important and we want that
we want to
ensure that we have to enforce that
thing and one way to import that is to
make sure that
the encoder when we go from the
observation to parameter
is to match the data that we have okay
so what we're going to do for the
previous way in ie neural network and
this
is basically we saw we want to learn a
lot of english problems we have a lot of
inverse problem then we're going to
learn the map
right okay so let's let's maybe give
some
example i think enough to talk about
purely data even let's give it some some
example very simple example relu
activation functions the parameter the
dimension of u
is about you know 4 000 up you know 1400
i'm sorry
1400 and you know um the key that here
is that
we use a lot of data so the data way
more than the number of primary that
that's important that you you can
see right so basically uh you have a a 5
000 pair of inverse problem that you
already know right for us is it easy we
just you know
uh uh synthetic right it is inside we
can do it but in
reality we may not have all right so can
can it learn
or not with purely data driven and when
you see parameter
data to parameter what what we mean is
that the algorithm code architecture
right from parameter to
to data and data back to a parameter and
this is the reverse one
and the true parameter is this this is
heat conduction problem
and this is the decoded estimation of
the two parameters and
it's the decoder estimation of true
parameters for the other technic
um uh architecture as well um and
as you can see right these are these are
for
i forgot to mention these are for when
you measure
the the the full domain right you
measure
observation everywhere this you measure
observation on the battery only
and you know you see this it's pretty
good right even with less number of data
but
because the measurement i'm sorry but
the the amount of data is so much that
you have
fifty thousand so it's not the price
that both of them do quite
uh well right equally all right so
actually give you a few numbers so that
you can
have a better feeling okay remember that
alpha is the regularization parameters
the this uh first two columns are the
full data
so and the battery data is the second
case where we use
these two to to do inverse problem
differently
and notice that you know this is the uh
outer
encoder technology so you can actually
not only estimate the parameters
or based on you can also learn the state
the solution
at the same time simultaneously okay so
as you increase the
the regularization parameter remember
that you force the latent variable to
either match so this one to match the
data the more you do it seem like you
get better results
right the battery data and full data
doesn't seem to be much different
now if you look at the other reverse
architecture
same same thing happens but remember
that inverse problem is what we care
about
and and for this architecture we don't
know right this is purely data or even
approach
they use the same data this approach
somehow actually better which we don't
understand and that's another the
problem with purely data driven
when you get you get what you get right
um
and it's hard it's i don't know but you
can come some of you can help
and that's exactly the motivation for
the the following method development on
top
later so this is for 3d the previous
problem with 2d
now we have 3ds and you see right at the
dimension increase with the same amount
of data now
the error is much higher even though the
reverse
architecture is actually half of the the
error but it's still very high
okay so um so the first approach that i
have shown you for the take home message
for the purely data ribbon
uh deep learning approach is the
following it may not be
trivial interpretable or interprets the
book right
so it's it's it's harder to understand
what's going on behind the scenes
um at least for me it's not clear and
then there's a massive amount of data in
order to be reasonably uh accurate
and that's what we observe and we want
to share with you and i think
most of you understand that as well so
the second approach is
is uh it's an effort to to combine
reducing model and deep learning right
to learn the forward and and
an english problem at the same time so
uh
this is the first effort that we try in
the sense that we know the reducing
model
keep the physics right but it's half
error yongsu can talk you about tell you
about that
and he worked on moderate reduction
before um
so we want to keep the physic but at the
same time we want to increase the
accuracy of the the rom and reducing the
model
so the the the obvious idea is that okay
how about this i'm going to learn the
error
between the two solutions and the
reduced solution right
and we use an uh an error estimator to
estimate the error
and from that from that we're gonna
learn but you see that's the reducing
model
and uh this is the error this is the the
multiplication multiplied
you know multiplicative neural networks
so there's two neural networking one
learned about the other learned
the actual error and that's actually
helped learn
better okay so you have when you have
two net network
there you you just simply you know
optimize both of the
uh weight biases for both network at the
same time
and uh the key remember that the key for
us is to to solve right one you train a
network
you're going to replace you know replace
the forward model with the neural
network
reducer amount of producer model plus
neural network
and you know you don't need to solve the
full forward problem anymore but just
reduce
model right so so that's that's the key
all right so let's let's see some
results this is um the
heat conduction problem 2d again
this is a high fidelity model inverse
result so this is just
you know inverse straight inverse from
standard classical english deterministic
and this is the reducing model without
doing it and anything just using
reducing the model
and this is the the corrected remember
that reducing the model plus deep
learning
and you see that we get better right way
better inverse solution
and you may ask how about objects you
purely data driven to learn the inverse
problem and this is what you get right
with the same amount of data
you get more worse results and for for
for your information this is a little
bit more detail on what to do
on these about right full model time the
reducer model this is the relative error
right
and time and reducing model plus the
discrepancy
right or or deep learning model you see
that we can
get the dial the error is almost the
same order of magnitude or almost the
same as the full order
right if you do deep learning of chile
data ribbon alone
to learn the english moment you have
much higher error but you know you run
faster so you see that
uh and this one compromise right it's a
little bit slower than the reducing
model
but it's it's it's way more accurate and
that's that's the
the the beauty right okay so
uh and this is what uh john and uh
marvin and jim and their students uh
it's a collaboration with them
i'm not gonna go into this problem i
don't know much about it it's just the
neutron transport six dimension problem
just give you an example i'm not going
to go to detail because i don't know i
think john i think i saw him coming
maybe
if you ask a question john can answer
the question but the key is here again
similarly right
if you run along alone right you can
have
a high an error but you use uh you can
correct
the rom with deep learning right depends
on dimension and this is another beauty
of doing this right
we know that reducing model can make
error but this approach right our the
approach that we
we we're doing here say that okay you
can make a very large error in the
reducing model by using
a few reduced basis right and then let
deep learning to learn and yet you still
can get pretty good right of course it
cannot be better than than
if you make the rom better in other
words you can improve
you can make it more accurate or you can
make it significantly more accurate
depends on
your ability to do reducing the model
okay
um so the the second message for the
second approach that we
uh have been talking is that we want to
combine right the physic that
contained by the traditional approach in
this case reducing the model
and which at the same time we still
being as fast as reducing model we don't
want it to way more
slower than reduce the model and in
order to do that we actually just
very very simple idea just take the deep
learning to learn but of course you have
to tweak
that there right you just simply learn
the error you may have problem
but if you if you actually you are any
indicator or
error estimator and again this is a
beauty to to yield a traditional applied
mathematical
approach to improve or to adapt deep
learning for the purpose of science and
engineering applications and then show
i have shown you that is our form the
data purely data ribbon approach
and that's that's the main message for
for the second approach okay
the third one model constraint deep
learning approach
this session have no results so my
student high still working on
numerical results but i'm going to share
you some ideas right by the way on the
top
on the thing that i'm showing you here
either appear in paper or an archive so
let me know if you're interested and i
can send you
the the appropriate references now
recall recall this this naive approach
in which you want to learn the inverse
map directly right and remember that we
actually do regularization
symbol regularization for the way and
biases okay so
now we're not going to do it you know
we're not going to regulate this way
we're going to say
we know herrera is a very very very
different way we use physic here
uh what what do we mean by that we want
the inverse map right you see deep
learning to take that observation to the
uh
to the data we want it such in such a
way that
when it returned the the parameter
and when we push the push the parameter
through the forward this is the
true underlying forward my mathematical
problem when we push it through the
forward underlying forward map
we want to recover data right so you
think that this is the
the two different one is like you can
you can think it's a physics
right a model constraints uh deep
learning or you know physic
you know give me one precedent form i
know george actually gave a talk few
there
months ago or so if you want to
physically inform yes this is a physical
form regularization right you can think
that way
um and what do we get for for that case
what is the difference you already see
the solution that i saw you before
now for linear inverse problem linear
neural net what do we get for this case
so of course you can write out everybody
can do it
but uh but the key is this the key is
this
when you actually figure when you
actually plug them to find out
the solution of different and become mc
model constraint differently in this
case
it is in fact a solution of the uh uh
railways linear inverse problem in other
words now we have we can interpret right
um the the solution of deep different
due to the physics
right so the beauty of that physics term
is allow us to actually understand the
machine learning or deep learning
solution better and we can show
at least for linear okay it is nothing
more than the rare right
solution of the traditional approach
right so that equivalent
so so that's actually we feel very happy
of course for non-linear
we don't know but for linear you can see
that the immediate connection between
the model constraint approach and the
traditional approach here
all right so of course if we can do for
the
learning the forward map inverse map
directly you can do for the outer
encoder technology that i showed you
before
as well right so as you see that this is
the
this is these two terms you saw
previously
that this is the new term which is the
model constraint we want
the the outer encoders right after you
get it right
you just solve for the solutions right
whatever the map it is when it goes
through the form
it must match the data so that's that
that's what we want and this is the
physics
uh based term okay
um and we can we can we can prove a
couple of things again for a linear
problem
for non-linear we don't know how to do
it we we can show that for that that
the decoder or and water constraint
decoder system for linear inverse
problem and linear neural network we can
show that okay that
the encoder waves is in fact the true
forward map it's interesting right
and the decoder is a the left inverse of
the forward map which is what we want it
to be
we want to we expect it that way right
because remember that the encoder try to
learn the
the forward map and the decoder try to
learn the inverse map
and what is it this may not be really
important but this is actually more
you know this is how you interpret that
solution if you we
find that the universe block solution if
you get a solution from any method we
define that is a
equivalent solution right or the
solution is equivalent to the true
underlying parameter
if you put the true parameter through
the forward map and you put your
solution whatever the method
you that you have through the fourth map
they match that's what we call
equivalent inverse solutions
and the beauty is that the mc model
constraint decoder inverse solution is
an
equivalent one right so in in the same
it's actually behaved like
the true underlying uh parameters
okay so that's a that's a uh that's the
that's uh uh something that i want to
share
of course right you can you can also do
mc encoder which i don't have time to to
talk about here
i'm gonna move forward but the technical
message
is that we use we use the mathematical
underlying mathematical model to to
train to verilize
the neural network and you can show for
the mcn encoder you get an equivalent
english
solution for the mc encoder which i
don't don't show here
you get a consistent solutions so so um
and without that thesis term you cannot
actually talk about these
um okay so like i said we don't have the
numerical result yet actually we do have
but not not substantially or
enough for me to show uh let me go to
the last attempt uh
on the statistical approach uh jung-su
how much how many more men do i have
it was three now it's only two okay
okay
i'm not sure well how well i'm doing
with at least one of those so it's more
like two but
um yeah i i have not
gotten an update from her um
lately i think
i'm sorry somebody say something yeah i
mean
yeah nathan if i don't know if you're
talking
okay and anyway you have enough time um
okay
yeah yeah but i i thought that we have
only i have only two minutes
whoever per person say i don't have two
minutes
i would say okay you didn't account at
that time that we we we lost a few
minutes
at the beginning anyway we have enough
time
so i'm gonna uh go through this uh not
quick right i i'm like don't think
quickly but i can i may skip some slides
all right now let us recall the model
constraint remember that we start with a
purely
purely data ribbon and then we have a
model constraint what is the model
constraint does
it it's encoded the underlying
mathematical model as a regularization
right question how to use alpha um
okay so if we actually looking a little
bit more
uh uh closely right if you solve inverse
problem before this is sound like a
misfit problem
right this is the misfits term the
missive sphis term should actually scale
by the
the noise uh covariance right and if you
look at this term
it looks more like the the prior term
right because u minus something right a
prior term
it suits regularized here as well you
should put the correct norm here as well
because if not
we may have problem and finally right
remember the fee is the the uh the map
from the observation to the
parameter right and we don't want we
want we don't want the parameter to
behave wildly right if you do inverse
problem before we when we only restrict
the the the solution in some sentient
enough restrict it
in a sense that you are close to some
predetermined
values in some particular norm right for
the
asian inverse problem we know that the
the correct
weighted norm is the coherent inverse of
the covalent okay
so uh so this is the first one try to do
to compare with the naive one
but we come back we stand back and say
okay how about this
we want to do something more you know uh
rigorous in a sense that it's taking
into account the inverse problem
what should these things is it a correct
way right
of course it's easily the natural thing
that we should do to
put the coherency of the universal
covariance here
and we also need to to to um to um
enforce
the growth right you don't want this so
the english solution will grow
so that doesn't a natural thing to do
but is is it good and
and you know intuitively and
and and and the way that i just
show you right it's it's a natural to do
so but can actually we get some from
some mathematical model
and here we go it's interesting that is
it's
heuristic argument here that i just show
you uh can actually obtain from a more
reverse model and this is what we're
gonna try to talk next
right uh and and this is the model
constraint variation or atom color
we're not gonna use the other encoder at
that usual way right if you do every
encoder you know
and you do variation you know as well
this is
not what we do we actually we try to put
the the underlying mathematical model
inside the variational encoder how do we
do it here we go
we assume that the posterior i i i've
apologized
for those who actually uh don't know
english problem before right i didn't
have time to introduce english problem
but you know let me just quickly to
tell you what it means right the
posterior is the solution or english
problem it's just the probability
density right so please
bear with me on that accept that fact so
and that is always expensive
to deal with like i mentioned before the
curse of dimensionality how do you deal
with that because
each time you do a symbol of the
posterior
to see inside the exterior you're
required to solve the forward map
forward equation which is expensive so
the whole
you know the whole thing behind the
bayesian english problem is how to cut
down the cost of
assembling or to explore the posterior
right without solving the many
so much the forward problem that's
that's always the key behind the scene
how you can do it
so in this case we're going to do
variance variation approach if you know
variational approach
the idea is to approximate a posterior
with some
distributions right and the distribution
is parameter
parametrized by some parameter we're
going to talk about the parameter later
for now
don't worry about the parameters one of
we want to wish to file parameters such
that our approximate
uh invasion or you know posteriors
is close to the true posterior in some
sense
what do we mean by one something here
we're not going to yield a traditional
so this is the traditional kl diversion
so if you take alpha
equal to uh to uh one yes
alpha equal to one you get the
traditional uh kl right
or variational approach we don't do that
we look at the
more uh generic um
functional in this case it's actually
called alpha diversion
and you see that's a jensen right this
is basically
jensen's shaman if alpha equal to one
half this is nothing more than
jensen and shannon divergence okay
so uh this is an additional term and
this term you see is expensive right
because the posterior is here
this is the approximate posteriors which
is much cheaper
all right so uh that's a starting point
and if you know
a variational approach it's always try
to find an upper bound right and try to
find a computable upper bound and try to
minimize up about
instead of minimizing this functional
because it's too expensive
and it's it's easy for you for um you
know when i say
you know it's just algebra it's not
difficult you can show right you can
show that
the junctions uh shaman here
diversion plus this term the ko
diversion between the approximate
posterior
and the posterior but it's let about it
above by these three terms
right and of course you know right you
you know that
the the the lower bound will actually
equal to zero when the
approximate steroid is equal to
posterior for both both of the terms
so instead of minimizing this we're
going to minimize the upper bound so
that's not the key idea
so immediately upper bound we have two
three terms
to deal with and i put the color on
publicity here right
so we had the approximate posterior here
that we have to deal with and we had the
posterior
so the question is what is the what is
the
approximate posterior what is the serial
form right
because as soon as we find a suitable
form or computable form of the
approximate posterior
you can actually can compute the last
two terms because the last two term
depends on only on the approximate
exterior
and the likelihood on the prior not
double sphere itself but
the latter the first term is actually
more difficult because it is
the character version of the true versus
the
the the approximate okay how coming on
how are we going to do it
so we're going to do it in one shot yeah
actually the question are
separate but if you address if you
address the question
on the approach maybe theory it turns
out that you can also address the
question of how to approximate the first
time as well
and this is what i'm going to show you
all right now remember that these are
the
approximate posterior what we're going
to do here like traditional variation
approach
we're going to we're going to assume
that we're going to learn
the the the the gaussian distribution
the difference
the difference is that under naturally a
traditional variation approach is that
the posterior mean approximately
posterior mean
and and the covariance is actually given
by the deep neural net right the
dictionary net taken
uh that observations right and weights
and returned
the the approximately theorem mean and
the covariance so that's that that
that's the the the parameter remember
that i mentioned that the
the this actually family depends on
parameter what are these what are this
parameter it's actually nothing more
than the
way and biases of the neural network
right so so that's answer the question
if you have
before and in your mind anyway give me a
question please stop me
now uh what we're going to do is that
we're going to train right as soon as we
can train this
map we can learn the posterior um
mean and and the approximate covariance
and therefore
the the approximate posterior and if you
know the approximate posterior you can
evaluate these two terms
right cheaply so how do we do it we just
simply take withdrawal symbols we don't
throw a symbol from the prior
if you do invasion uh inverse problem we
always assume we make a very strong
assumption that
drawing from the player is always easy
okay in code
it may not be easy all right and then
once you have the draw
you pass it through the forward map and
add some noise or you know
because this is synthetic or data right
so we add some noise we had observation
that's how we get
the training point okay so
we we're gonna so basically that this
test is is is
what the training of this the training
test is nothing more than
learning from mt inverse problem right
because because this is the map from the
observation from the parameter to
observation
so we assume that we have an
analytically or synthetic
inverse pair parameter to observation
and we want to learn the map right we
want to learn
the map between these by by training all
right
that's not not a surprise now
the first term it turns out the first
term actually can can approximate as
well
we should do one more approximations
first
you see that the the the last the first
term which is this one is
bothering because this is that
expectation with respect to the
posterior the true one which is
expensive we try to avoid it
it's the beauty here is that if you
replay the posterior with the
with the prior right um actually
before doing that sorry i'm going to do
one more step i'm going to decompose
right the posterior into the
um uh the ratio due to these two terms
right because we know log is a negative
that's not
a surprise and this is actually not zero
we actually
cross that out because it does not
depends on the parameter fee
right no remember that we do
minimization with respect to
to feed here so this they're not
dependent on ph so it's not a problem
now these terms uh the only problem with
the posterior what we're gonna do is
that we
we're gonna replace we're gonna replace
the theory with the prior
and interestingly we have we get an
upper bound okay
and and it's it's consistent with the
variation approach
as soon as you go to up about up about
and then you might minimize up about
uh you know in the same intuitively it
should be good right you don't want to
minimize
the low value right so you minimized up
about so
with this new upper belt we completely
independent of the posterior
and what we don't want to do is that we
want to do a very very
uh bad approximation we use only one
symbol right
only approximately this only one samples
and it's actually quite well known
that in variation approach one symbol is
is a pretty good
right you can do more but first the
result that we're going to show you
later we use only one symbol
all right now i'm going to put
things everything together everything
together remember that we approximate
uh these two terms by a gaussian and
through the different net and
we are we approximate with this one with
the upper bound and we minimize
right remember that so so now our
problem our problem when we putting
all these things together our problem
now not look like this it's a minimize
of of of three terms
and this interestingly uh i look very
familiar with what we did before what
heuristic right mc
dnm heuristically we want to learn the
map from the observation to the
parameter remember that this is a
different net right and we add the
uh physic term here and and remember
that we want the
the uh the the solution must be bowed in
some
some um some respected norm and we did
it heuristically
but this framework automatically
automatically automatically give us d2
so in other words
you can think about this framework
actually give us a justification of what
we did before right what we did before
just heuristic which
actually what we did before we
definitely we never know but later on
when we look at this framework
somehow it's recover which makes us very
happy
okay now i'll give you a couple of
examples let me end the talk
uh if it's uh john is that
one minute left zero minute left yeah
yeah yeah you have a time please okay
please
okay so um um this is
in in a way i'm gonna connecting a
little bit more visually for you
here right we we start from observation
we go through
right we go through a digital net
remember the different net take the
observation
and return the approximate theorem mean
and the covariance
right at the top if you have this you
can draw
a symbols right and from from the
approximate posterior and you pass it
through the
the forward map right so this this is
this is the home process that you can
see
so the this part of the process
corresponding to do minimization of this
right
and this part process is to do
minimization of the physics term here
so unlike the the traditional variation
of
outer encoder our approach actually have
the the physics term here
by going through the junction uh shannon
okay of course uh you may ask
you know can you actually prove
something about it and some way right we
we are engineer but we do apply math
research
so whenever the beauty of being an
engineer all right is that whenever we
can prove something we go
uh we prove otherwise we should go ahead
and go without an intuition and that's
the reason why we have the mcdnn before
right it's just way on our
intuition now let me simplify and see
whether we can prove something
again leaning was prob that's the key
leading inverse problem linear
neural network you can prove something
uh uh interestingly
right um if you assume that is the case
don't forget about the detail will look
complicated but it's not believe me it's
a linear jupiter
but the key is this the key is this box
if you
if you work with the linear inverse
problem you can show that
our framework returned approximately
posterior which is exactly the true but
zero mean
right the approximate stereo mean is the
true posterior
mean and the pressure posterior covalent
covariance
is in fact the true or posterior
covariance for the linear problem
okay so of course this linear inverse
problem uh you can do
a lot of things but the key thing is
that it give us
the confidence that this approach is
good right because if you know for
linear
whatever in the method that you develop
if it cannot work for a linear inverse
problem or linear problem then there's
no hope to
work for nonlinear that's not not my
opinion right of course
each of us have different opinion and
just to tell you why i do linear one
it's just a
you know sanity check anything in that
way of course you can
you can you don't need to do the the
remember that this is the physics term
if you want to do pure data driven usb
you can work without a framework
and to do purely data driven here right
to replace the different net here
instead of the the forward map all right
so let me give you an example here to
see
the results perhaps let me show you the
training process a little bit
this is the training process um
so this is the the posterior amine and
this is approximately theory i mean that
the training will go
uh go through there's a clip in between
it's not
the the the actual thing right don't
worry so you see that's no that one is
not
for some reason the movie is not doing
well my poster say so
at some point it's just flip back it's
not the the the
the true numerical result right it's
just the artifact of the
movie okay anyway the key is that you
can see as the after you
number it past go through you get closer
closer to the the truth
um posterior mean and you also have a
quantification of uncertainty here and
this is not linear inverse problem of
course right not not linear problem
okay but i hope i'm not going to go into
details here uh we only see movie
that actually moved to next uh um
examples and uh in fact should i
say okay let me actually skip this slide
it's not important
um you can actually increase we actually
we learn um
we try to see whether you know we you
increase the the
day training data we we look at the
different noises you see how it works
and the result is quite robust as you
can see right it's similar to what
you've seen before
so uh let me skip the uh detail up in
america hopefully you can see something
already
the the main message for for the last
part of the top is the
model constraint variation approach this
is another approach that we try to do
we learn the mean and the and and the
point y covariance of the the posterior
and we have seen that if you if you
equip the physic you can show right
at least your your result actually can
be interpretable right at least for the
linear case that you can learn the
posterior exactly
um all right and and for this case right
remember that i have to approach
purely data driven and and that and and
the
uh deep learning um right physical form
you can think that way
they don't actually very different they
don't they don't look very different so
we still don't understand why
we're still working on that it does not
seem to outperform the purely data
driven
perhaps the problem is too is it too
easy
that's what we get but we're not sure
all right so we have been working on
various aspects of of um
deep learning for science and
engineering problem let me show you a
couple of movie
this is you know you will try to learn
the forward map is the way propagations
for difference right you different in
not initial gap forcing terms you can
just learn and and see whether you can
predict the
um the solution of the wave propagation
for different source
and you see that you know by at least
the eyebore norm it's worked very well
the neural network revolution is here
it's look very
similar okay i just and this is the
3d inverse wave propagation the
earthquake problem that i showed you
before
right this is the error between the the
different net
which is um which is the
this one right and the true solution
resolution for 3d
uh sine squared inverse problem here you
see that we
do pretty well not i didn't have time to
go through we also look at very hyper
elasticity non-linear problems
uh and what i showed you here is that
the final element solution is in the red
points
and the new network prediction is the
blue uh wireframe you cannot distinguish
on the eye
on my eye right um of course this
because we encode the physic in there
and the error is actually five percent
on average
all right so we also talked we learned
we were working on uncertainty
quantification for different but
that's actually the key right how do you
know that deep learning is good so
um let me not go into details
i just wanted to tell you that we have
some result here to show
that not only we can predict but beyond
the solution of neural network but also
we can predict the
the error right and this actually this
is the
the the nips classification number uh
problems
and uh and um you know
the the the true one actually is two
right the
the true number is actually two and you
can see that the error is very small the
very very small the rest is actually the
error is actually big somewhere else
right because we we can predict we can
estimate that the
uncertainty is small there which is
makes sense
all right so uh uh i'm not gonna go into
details but i'm just trying to say that
we
have been making a few efforts to encode
the underlying mathematical model into
the
reason we do so not just we want to do
it it's just because the data is limited
and when we first tried the purely data
driven
it does not give us you know an
explanation what what does it what
actually what it does right it's just
a home complicated formulation but it's
not clear what it's going to do
for physics right or you if you encode
or you put the model inside the training
it turns out that you can do a few
things
at least you can prove a few things that
and and your result looks
meaningful in terms of that like closer
to traditional
mathematical approach but you know you
are much faster than using a traditional
mathematical approach
all right so i think i should stop now
thank you
thank you so much ken uh it was a
wonderful i i liked it
a lot um so um now let's move on to q a
session there was
uh one question from ryan but uh
between colin and ryan i guess the
question has been sorted out
so um without without
um you know inter intervened
from from the speaker that's great
that means a lot of interest from the
audience
so if you have any questions you can put
that question in the
uh the chat room or you can amuse
yourself and then
directly ask ask the questions okay
i'd ask a question uh is it ryan
yes yep yeah so so i'm just curious
um so
so i i'm interested if if one was for
example to solve
um solve a problem with machine learning
versus just doing pure bayesian
uh uq uh is there
pros and cons between that
or are they just sort of like different
tools to solve a problem
yeah so if you do the traditional
beijing approach
it is expensive so the main idea he
starts to
cut down the cost of the solvent
bayesian inverse problem especially
those who actually govern by pdes if you
have a pde behind the scene
that's that's a problem so what we have
been trying to do is to try to learn the
inverse map directly or the forward and
then use it to to do
faster inverse solutions so the the pro
is which we hope
is actually faster but we don't want to
make error fast right
because now we do approximation we make
error compared to the traditional
english bayesian invoice problem so the
idea
is to to not make fast error or to make
errors so fast
is from our point of view to encode the
the underlying mathematical model in
there
we haven't done actually extensive uh
solution
in fact we're gonna show we we have here
let me actually
show you i didn't have time to go into
details i know that it was i think over
time
um the accuracy is comparable
but more rigorous and more extensive
comparison should be done which we are
doing right now so this is actually
not even the traditional bayesian
inverse problem this is just a gaussian
approximation of the
divisions of posteriors right and then
and then you take the gaussian
covariance as the measurement of the the
error
so we we think we get a comparable thing
at least for the gaussian approximations
but the the true posterior and the true
uncertainty
required by you know assembling for
example by mcmc and compare again this
uh we haven't done it yet uh so in
summary
um it could be faster but whether it's
more accurate
or it's still not more accurate i don't
think so right
but it is can it still have some you
know
uh appropriate equivalence um accuracy
that that's still uh in research at
least numerically
by eyeball norm you can think that you
can say that they are similar
but theoretically we don't know
yeah on that vein
i'd also be interested so like if you if
you're doing this for like let's say
time dependent pde
and you had uh data up to some on some
time interval
and then you wanted to uh you know do
your machine learning and then wanted to
pr
to create like let's say a band of
uncertainty and
time uh for that uh you know
obviously you do have the bayesian
perspective but i'm like sort of curious
you know
i know like this is kind of a big
problem with machine learning mods when
trying to extrapolate
um things get tough so so i guess i
i i i sort of feel like that's like why
a lot of people in the uq community like
the beijing perspective because you can
get that band of uncertainty
um can can you get that in machine
learning and have some idea of
how well this is or if it's just bad
yeah yeah okay so that's that's actually
a great question ryan he actually
actually i show you here
okay first let me actually address the
question in extrapolation right
in fact that's the key thing right if
you try to extrapolate
if you use machine learning in an
extrapolation regime
it's going to be bad right the idea of
machine learning is not about
extrapolation but interpolation in a
sense
um so we try to avoid that and how do we
actually
at least one way to avoid attribution is
to encode the
mathematical underlying uh in there
mathematical
underlying model in there right the
physics term that i showed you before
so the machine learning to try to
interpolate the data but also
interpolate the
mathematical model right so that that
that's actually
your question is so great that i i
didn't have a chance to mention about
that
um so it's try to circumvent that that
situation
secondly with this variational right
model constraint variation
approach we actually can can can also
estimate uncertainty which is the band
here
so these are the results from from the
um
machine learning approach that we we we
develop here we not only
get the solution which is the mean here
right the the black is that the
is approximate solution mean and this is
the true underlying
one but but we also actually can can
talk about uncertainty here
yes we can we can estimate uncertainty
how good it is it needs to be uh uh
further study
but but we can in the lies similar to
the patient approach
okay well thank you uh
the next question is from rahul he asked
have nonlinear neural net variants
been tested for the auto
inversion model
he asked have non-linear neural network
variants
been tested for the auto inversion model
so i i i mean okay um okay let me go
back to that slide okay so
variance remember that the auto
inversion thing that i did before that's
a deterministic thing
okay so uh we don't have we have the
results
which i show you here but you should see
the deterministic results um
because that traditional outer encoder
is a deterministic way
so it cannot estimate uncertainty or
variance
uh at least the way that we use right
now
and uh how do we do how we actually
estimate the variance if
i'm trying to answer the question i'm
not sure whether that's what you're
asking for
you know if you if you don't mind please
just you know turn on a video to
talk microphone and ask the question
again perhaps but this approach
is a deterministic so it does not give a
variance
right as opposed to the variation or
approach that i showed you in the last
few minutes
where we actually not only predict the
solution but also the variance
does it answer your question rahul if
you are around
maybe it's not um yeah maybe
maybe it's not okay um so i i don't see
any more questions from the cube you
know the chat box but
uh um i i do have some questions um when
you
uh train the auto encoder for example uh
what what sort of the convergence rate
do you observe
how fast it is and how slow they are etc
can you comment on that
the training process yeah training of
the auto encoder
that's okay that's that's a good
question i i wish that my postdoc is
here
i i i don't know actually i don't know
the details uh
sorry about that i cannot answer that
question all right
typically very slow i mean this is a
general thing right and that's that's a
problem with
with the machine learning approach
unless and
and actually that your question is that
lead to the important point
because the machine learning if you
train you spend a lot of time and if you
just afford solve a forward problem it's
not worth it
right the machine learning techniques
at least for pde type of problem it's
useful
when you do for problem for propagation
uncertainty where you need to solve
forward many times
right or you solve the inverse problems
right
many times or or you know you need to
evaluate the forward problem many times
then this
becomes uh useful because the inverse
problem itself is very expensive
it's only useful or only for me from my
point of view
to do machine learning if you solve b
kind of problems
because otherwise training takes a lot
of time you see
generally a lot of data and you learn if
you do machine learning you know before
if you learn you know it's just a
standard stochastic grading the same old
atoms
and with many parts it's just it's run
for what can be forever depend on also
your network architecture as well
by the way i didn't talk about that we
also do research on
architecture design because how many
neurons how many uh layers right yeah
yeah
that's all right top top question the
more layer that you have one unit that
you have
it takes much longer time to to trim
it's it's
yeah generic answer you spread slow
how slow i don't know okay so
follow my my question uh the rahu asked
this question how much computation of
course
does the trained model offset as
compared to the full order model
so i i guess you don't have a good
detailed answer because
you have you don't have a postdoc with
you yeah if
if you can comment on that good question
good question i think uh i
at least let me actually show you maybe
back to the
uh re only the reducer model actually we
actually uh
you know recorded the thing right the
other one we didn't record we
again let me just make sure that that is
think clear right
this is just that time that we do and we
we just see whether we can recover a
solution in some sense okay
um so we haven't actually make an effort
to to measure or
is it worth or is more than upset the
the solution of traditional or the
training
um uh uh cost okay so
even this we actually didn't actually
compare or we didn't actually put the
training cost here
i wish that my student is here but you
know thinking about this thinking about
if you need to solve the inverse problem
many times this is what you get for the
um because this is very small problem
you don't see much
of the the game but uh it's like more
less than half
right if you solve the problem any time
and
uh and and of course if this actually
more than offset the the time that you
do training then it's worth it
right otherwise it's not worth it i
agree so i i
that the the question is very important
but unfortunately we haven't actually
spent time
doing you know the real rigorous record
of all the things to see whether it's
actually good
in terms of timing or not i see
okay so i have another question if you
go to the previous slide
the the slide 23 okay
um and yeah so there
um so do you you combine the deep
learning with the view student model and
in terms of video student model you
introduce the fee
here inside of the residual term
right i i guess this fee is your reduced
basis
right yeah this is basis yes and there
are many ways of constructing this
reduced spaces
how how do you construct it oh yeah
that's good question
yeah more than reduce your model uh
question now okay
so we do it in the model constraint way
as well uh
um zhongsu so we we do a greedy approach
we uh we minimize the error between the
reduced and full models thinking about
this right this is the
reduced model forget about the tudor
here this is a reducer model
right this is a full model forget about
a regularization term here
we try to find a parameter at which
the error between the full model let's
say that you have a current reducing
model with
zero basis vectors how do i find the
next space of vectors okay
so i minimize the error between the full
model and the reducing model
you find a parameter i'm sorry not mean
i'm maximized
basically i i want to find in the
parameter space
right at which parameter our reducer
model is the worst
okay and then i take that parameter i
saw the forward
solution and i get that into the basis
and i
i i i construct a new reducer model with
that enriched
basis and then i do it again and again
right for the new reducer model
you maximize the error between the phone
and reduce right to find a parameter
in the worst case in your parameters
and then take the solution and that
works case in inner parameter
into your basis right by doing that you
can see right you can maybe you're
thinking about an
error surface we try to find in the air
surface which one is the maximum and
bring the
maximum error down in the aero surface
between the reducer model and the full
model
right right okay so so there are also
the issue
of the curse of dimensionality if you
have a
the higher dimension in your parameter
space than the number of
samples you have to include in your
greedy algorithm
sure sure increasing exponentially
yeah yeah but here's the beauty actually
it could be right depends on how you use
it
um we actually rely on the optimization
in high dimensional space if it's for
sure it's difficult right but if you do
pde it turns out right actually
i think it's actually can be improved
that if you use newton type of technique
we would which we do newton type of
optimization technique with tradition
what we do behind the scene
just region newton cg you can show that
actually
the the number of iteration is actually
independent of the of the
the parameter dimensions as soon as you
resolve the physics
okay of course if you go from two and
two to ten parameters right you refine
the mesh
the the the dimension the parameter
dictated by the mesh of the parameter
match
uh i mean i i didn't prove it but uh but
i
i have the result to show you uh but no
i don't have it here
basically showing that if you refine the
mesh stock
to a certain point increase the math
beyond that
does not increase the the cost basically
you actually capture on the
on the information in the data
and with newton method the number
parameter number of iteration will be
fixed
okay yeah thank you tan um
um is there any other questions i mean i
i have um one of the questions on the
you know the auto encoder where you map
the from the solution to the parameter
and parameter to the solution
i thought there was a pretty interesting
idea
um but in the in the context of the time
dependent problem by the by the way
so your parameter does not change uh
with time
right but the solution
may change throughout the time right
so i i don't know how you you know map
those
time dependence states with a time
independent parameter
and then map back to the time dependent
uh states
okay so that's how would you deal with
that uh for the
time dependent problem yeah yeah that's
a good question uh you know
but the the the actually the idea is
still the same remember that
if you look at right remember that we
learned actually where is the forward
map and the app is a word map
it's okay so the fourth map what is the
forward map the forward map take the
parameter to
observations right the obvious elevation
can be in time
yeah okay yeah so in the same the the
um the um the forward map actually does
not actually see the discretization
it says just see a whole bunch of
measurements right
for the the forward map it just it's
mathematically a map from the
observation
parameter to observation and the
observation is a whole bunch of points
and these home puncher point is the
observation that you make over times
you just collect them onto one big
vector for example right i see so if you
connect them into one big vector this is
still the observation
and this is the parameter and this is
the observations
okay because the forward map does not
see that
the time discretization in there in a
sense okay
okay so so you you treat the whole space
time solution as a one
one um state solution and then map that
to
uh the parameter notice that we don't go
through the state uh john sue this is
important
right there's no stay in here it's just
the observation that and
only the observation okay and the
parameters right the states
the states is just the middle mean it's
it's and it's actually
uh go through and that actually you
don't see it because
it's it is embedded inside the forward
map the forward map is not from the
parameter to observations okay
okay um any other question from the
audiences i'm
i guess i asked too much too many
questions
i don't see it from the chat room
um so well then if you don't have
uh any more questions please let's thank
uh the
the tent well we had like in like
in the middle of the top period rahu
said he have quite a few
yeah please email me okay we we can we
can chat
by email or you know we can meet and you
know personally up in private
yeah that'll be awesome i mean that's
that's what this seminar
is for um okay wonderful
all right let's thank our speaker um
professor tanbuy it was wonderful talk i
really enjoyed it and i hope
i i really i do think that the audiences
enjoyed it a lot too um thank you so
much for the great talk
and i hope that this is the starting
point of the the future collaboration
between lawrence livermore and other
external uh
audiences with uh the times uh
from ut austin and uh
um yes i mean um thank you so much tan
uh for the great talk and thank you uh
we will keep in touch right sure sure
sure yeah
thanks a lot for the opportunity i i
really enjoy talking
uh to all of you take care
thank you thank you so much everyone bye
now bye
hey if you can send send the pdf version
um
oh yeah sure sure yeah yeah i will do it
are you
excluding the uh the movie yeah i would
do it i would do it after this okay
i'll talk later bye